j'ai maintenant le plaisir de vous dire
que notre invité n'est autre que jean
gabin je vais le rejoindre avec plaisir
cher jean gabin je suis frappé de voir
ce monsieur respectable dans ce fauteuil
alors que je vous ai vu dans le film
d'audiard
il est respectable par la poésie et la
sympathie qu'inspire le bonhomme mais
c'est un drôle de bourlingue nommé plus
base reste un personnage c'est assez
marrant à rust un personnage d'un
personnage agréable donc on s'aperçoit
d'ailleurs qu'il a bourlingué dans sa
tête beaucoup plus qu on les monte
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de gomme
seulement mairie énervé c'est chouette
comme ça bien sûr c'est bon d'avoir de
retrouver les aventures dans sa poche
l'érosion est en fait vous avez fait
quelques marins dans votre carrière vous
aviez fait un bien bon marin à remorque
c'est le sol c'est le seul le seul jeu
poids j'ai tourné en vain que l'on
manque
et pourtant vous avez été mal mais
justement marine d'ailleurs aux
premières et vous vous étiez vous aviez
un petit pompon
terrab pendant ton nom pendant mon haïti
louis et pompon rouge puis a pas eu
pendant la guerre quand même je
commençais à prendre un peu de de bouche
ont fusé on a une casquette gts dont m à
victor kluba c'est donc un un
bourlingueur de rêve
d'ailleurs je dois ajouté john avec la
casquette collier dans le film oui c'est
ma casquette simple c'est ma casquette
de ce don pour le maillot à ça c'était
émouvant et aux non je mange
il avait prêté vous l'avez le v1 vous
apprêtez vous l'avait louée à non mal et
mon boss qui la met et qui la mettait
sur sa tête dans les grands pays
vulgaire coup et je veux prendre ma
casquette
il faut dire que michel audiard dans ce
film a amorcé un virage dans son oeuvre
parce que si le titre continue à être un
titre à la audiard un titre à la audiard
le drapeau noir flotte sur la marmite
ray par contre le ton est différent car
il ya beaucoup de tendresse et beaucoup
de poésie
maintenant les 15 ans qui viennent un
genre plus violents oui moi je pense que
ce taux futur amant charme de ces
l'adaptation d'un roman de rené fallet
km mais il était un petit navire était
un homme qui ne vire
d'ailleurs j'avais beaucoup titre qui
raconte bien d'ailleurs le ton d'une
chanson d'enfants c'est bien ce que
vient le temps du film et donc vous avez
vous et beaucoup de partenaires dont
notre ami jacques n'a qu'un rôle
important et j'ai pendant qu'on lui
parce qu'il avait été avec moi dans
plusieurs films avec michel on l'a eu
l'idée doit prendre parce que
physiquement il était tout à fait
personnel
c'est bien pour lui qu il m'est agréable
surtout fait du bien de savoir qu'il ait
un rôle un peu importe et puis y'a
jappeloup troquant et eric dame
il est bien beau mais quand il est bien
plus le poc a beau du tout et vous
formez un couple très sympathique parce
qu'en fait vous entraînez l'un à l'autre
à aux rêveries vous découvrez l'île au
trésor de stevenson ensemble et c'est à
dire que 8 points
c'est lui qui vous le fait connaître
j'aimerais qu'il me plaît pas lui qui me
l'a fait connaître
non mais on se garde le conages bon et
comment ça s'est passé le tournage avec
hélas non parce qu'on dit toujours que
qu'un comédien chevronné doit se méfier
des enfants pour pourquoi est une
légende du cinéma
oui j'ai dû les gens nos des fois il y
en a qui sont un peu cabot gpo souvent
c'est pas de leur faute c'est de la
faute des parents et apprentis son cabot
jeu les parents sont toujours là
derrière précise attendre son manager
jean temps mais je dois dire que je suis
là et cham les charmants et l'époque à
vos points on est très agréable
elle s'est donc arrêté lui vous promener
autour du monde sans quitter villeneuve
saint georges qui est la banlieue de
prédilection de rené fallet d'ailleurs
et que vous avez reconstitué au
demeurant je pensais vous aviez tourné
sur place mais nous on a été bon
oui le on a reconstitué le toute
l'histoire du bateau qu'on mais il ya
pas mal de choses qui sont tournées
quand même du côté de villeneuve saint
georges quand même enfin si l'on veut
savoir comment un info marins de saint
malo pu s'introduire dans les milieux de
la sncf à villeneuve saint georges et
faire du bateau dans un jardin dans un
jardin oeuvre une même ça on n'a pas ces
quelques images ya quinze jours à
monsieur cinéma
oui il faut aller voir le drapeau noir
flotte sur la marmite je croise un film
charmant et en fait l'expression de
l'expression drapeau noir je pense
qu'elle a tenté michel parce que le
drapeau noir c'est le drapeau des
boucaniers
oui oui et non
j'ai à vous dire c'est michel curieux
personnage il prétend qui m'a pris cette
expression 1 - d'ailleurs lé pa moin
parce que c'est une très vieille
expression mais il fut un temps où après
la guerre
ma situation n'était pas au cinéma
n'était pas tellement en luisant du nord
les choses et je disais que cette époque
là le rhin pour noire flottait sur la
marmite et alors il a pris ce titre le
drapeau noir flotte sur la marmite qui
m'a attribué à moi qui les pros du coup
à moi d'ailleurs pour faire bouillir la
marmite à cette époque faisait tourner
pas mal de films en italie et vous
appelez ça votre campagne d'italie et la
campagne d'anna et bien en tout cas le
campagne de france elle est bonne mais à